est-ce que vous souvenez de la mutualité
il ya huit mois
il ya huit mois nous avions fait le
serment de la mutualité à l'égard de
simone veil et nouveau nous lui avions
dit simone vous pourrez être fiers de
nous eh bien je crois qu'aujourd'hui
vous qui êtes ici
élu par les quarante cinq mille
militants de notre formation politique
parti est issu de formation bien connus
d'autres sont des adhérents directs
directement adhérents je préfère cette
expression je tiens d'abord à vous
féliciter de cette élection à vous dire
que nous sommes fiers de vous parce
qu'on quelques mois avoir réussi à vous
organiser à organiser les les fichiers
le mode d'élection de trancher des
ambitions légitimes de trancher des
débats d'aider l'équipe
alors que nous étions dans un provisoire
absolue enfants d'une d'une analyse
politique mais en même temps d'une
émotion de la mutualité
nous avons vécu dans un provisoire
invraisemblable pendant huit mois
un provisoire au plan national avec une
toute petite équipe qui à 4,5 personne
est obligée d'organiser de gérer tout ça
la mise en place d'une commission
nationale d'arbitrage et vraiment je
voudrais saluer le travail de jean
léonce dupont est tout ce conseil
national qui est indispensable car il ya
des arbitrages à effectuer dans une
création de formations comme celles là
la commission de transparence financière
indispensable
présidée par yves jean bart disais
et michel mercier et puis la commission
préparation des investitures c'est le
comité exécutif qui désigne qui a été
aussi amené à faire un travail
considérable
je voudrais vraiment vous dire que vous
êtes les piliers les élus démocratique
et les garants de notre famille
politique
et pour cette élection que vous avez à
laquelle vous avez été candidat et pour
lesquels vous avez été élu je voudrais
très sincèrement au nom de tous bureau
politique vous adresser un message de
félicitations et de très grande fierté à
bhl
dans cette période de création qui est
enfin souvenez vous il ya huit mois
terre regardé avec condescendance voire
peu d'ironie où chacun guetter les
couacs les incompréhensions les
divisions les micros se tendent est plus
naturellement pour essayer de trouver
des failles évidemment qu'il ya les
perceptions différentes des regards
différents des territoires nous sommes
les enfants de nos territoires et nous
regard sur la société sont pas les mêmes
selon les territoires c'est évident des
générations différentes
mais finalement petit petit lala lax
centrale l'axé central social libéral
européen s'est imposé nos parlementaires
européens j'allais lire nos
parlementaires européennes aussi car
dominique huez entouré de beaucoup de
femmes que je salue ont fait entendre
leur voix au ppe au parlement européen
notamment sur les sujets de
développement durable de co2 de
transparence d'exception culturelle au
sénat groupe sénatorial et à l'assemblée
le groupe à l'assemblée qui aujourd'hui
travaillent de conserve et je voudrais
remercier et saluer le groupe sénatorial
et son président françois zocchetto ces
deux groupes se sont petit à petit
imposé dans le paysage parlementaires
français nous avions dit une opposition
déterminée résolu mais constructive
compte tenu de l'état du pays déterminés
nous l'avons été nous avons été les
premiers à critiquer quelque chose de
très important pour la confiance je ne
sais plus quel
lequel de nos amis qui regardaient le
regard sur la france de loin
l'attractivité de la france le mou de
confiance à l'extérieur un candidat la
présence de la république ait pu dire
aux yeux et aux oreilles de tous les
européens qu'ils renégocierait un traité
qui était déjà signée par les européens
était une marque d'incompréhension voire
de désinvolture à l'égard de nos
partenaires européens qui étaient tout à
fait critiquable alors que à l'évidence
ce n'était pas faisable
et là le mensonge en interne français
qui a fait qu'une partie de l'électorat
très à gauche qui a cru à cette remise
en cause s'est sentie et trompait plus
de confiance en europe et trahisons en
france cela faisait beaucoup nous avons
été les premiers à dénoncer la mascarade
du pseudo pacte de croissance de 120
milliards d'euros alors qu'en réalité
cher dominique nous savons que le retard
de paiement de trésorerie des factures
de la commission européenne frise plutôt
les vents 25 milliards et qu'il y a
comme chacun de ses pas un euro de plus
pour l'instant
dans le débat et le budget lui-même pour
la période suivante est plutôt inférieur
nous avons dénoncé hervé la chape de
plomb fiscales et sociales n'ont pas sûr
sur chacun des points mais parce que au
moment où on voyait que après la crise
des liquidités qu'elles étaient
terribles en 2008 et donc la récession
qui en était suivi la croissance reparte
et et l'asphyxient général le sentiment
que personne ne savait comment ils
allaient être traitée manger et donc un
risque de récession majeure le mot
récession a été prononcée par nos à
l'assemblée nationale est
malheureusement en ordonnant la date à
l'époque l'avons dénoncé ce climat de
stigmatisation du monde économique et de
l'esprit d'entreprise qui a accentué
comme le disait no
témoin tout à l'heure ce sentiment au
fond de la non bienvenue des créateurs
quels qu'ils soient
quelle que soit la nature de leurs savez
sentiment qu'on en a c'est qu'une partie
de l'idéologie française considère que
c'est là la création et la richesse
qu'est le problème alors que pour nous
c'est la pauvreté qu'est le problème est
qu'on ne s'exonère pas de ne pas faire
une politique pour les plus faibles
simplement en dénonçant ceux qui courent
plus vite que les autres et ça c'est une
erreur idéologique majeur
savez ça me fait penser à la loi sur le
logement il ya quelques mois dans une
crise de logement terre cette fois
consistait simplement à dire nous allons
imposer aux maires voyez c'est de la
faute des maires ciapa de création de
logements en france
mais depuis quand les les mairies ont
les financements depuis quand les
mairies ont les outils urbain elles
peuvent autoriser organisé et crée le
cadre c'est une façon de différé sur
d'autres le début d'une crise du
logement dont nous sommes pas près de
sortir nous avons été les premiers
cherchant talent a dénoncé l' incroyable
recul sur les chantiers thermique de
bâtiments et de l'écologie française
l'abandon de tous les grands chantiers
éco les hits de notre pays
ce héros vierge comme les autoroutes
ferroviaires qui consistait à mettre les
camions sur les trains les sorties de
porc de manière ferroviaire les grands
névés qui permettait de désenclaver
enfin l'espagne la france est en train
de devenir comme la république tchèque à
corridor international de camions le
canal seine-nord déjà financés dont on
avait déjà dépensé les 200 premiers
millions d'autres avant le canal qui
déjà à son pont pour surplomber la route
et cette espèce de discours consistants
dire maintenant mais ce n'est pas
financé mais commence à la région nord
pas de calais picardie avait mille neuf
cent millions sans regarder les
chantiers thermique des bâtiments dans
les logements savait qu'on met on en
faisait en 2010 on nous faisait 176000
au bout de la deuxième année on en fait
600 par mois actuellement
on a arrêté le programme des bâtiments
publics alors qu'on avait audités dans
chaque département ce qu'il était
nécessaire pour améliorer la performance
énergétique des bâtiments
et puis nous avons dénoncé cet absolu
fully de la mise en cause des services à
la personne
ce que dément de revenir là dessus j'en
dirai encore un mot tout à l'heure ça
fait partie des mesures d'urgence
dramatique et ça c'est le fruit d'un
problème idéologique
ils n'ont pas compris que les services à
la personne c'était pas une aide fiscale
pour les gens riches n'ont pas compris
que les services à la personne c'est est
un service populaire essentiellement
pour les femmes qui travaillent pas
seulement qui permet d'avoir des
solidarités et que tout se joue et à
l'organisation à la qualification et le
coût horaire est un secteur qui avait
créé 550 mille emplois et qui par
ailleurs avait augmenté de 40% ceux qui
étaient déjà dans le secteur et qui
travaillait pas assez d'heures par mois
on est en train de le massacrer et de le
détruire à en être à supprimer l' agence
des services à la personne qui est là
pour adapter en permanence car il faut
adapter en permanence
composée de 14 personnes à paris pour
faire ce cv donc on a fait cette
position mais une opposition
constructive
on a fait des propositions on a soutenu
les contrats d'avenir même s'ils sont
très imparfait main tendue à la jeunesse
qui est en plus grande difficulté
l'ensemble de quartier nous avons
soutenu l'accord interprofessionnel qui
permet la flexisécurité très récemment
donc nous sommes pas mis dans une
position dogmatique mais nous sommes
dans une position clairement clairement
déterminée alors nous étions dans le
provisoire et vous êtes notre parlement
vous êtes les élus de cette formation
c'est vous qui représentez les 45
militants aujourd'hui j'espère les cent
mille adhérents très bientôt
vous devez valider les grandes
orientations
vous êtes le parlement entre deux
congrès vous devez valider notre
organisation
vous devez animé sur le terrain les
débats vous devez animé sur le débat sur
le terrain les préparation des échéances
et le débat politique en harmonie
évidemment avec le siège
vous avez donc une mission majeure est
historique car au fond au fond ou lui
dit
c'était simplement un regroupement de
forcer parce qu'on tente de se retrouver
pour peser un peu plus où on pense que
c'est une formation décisive pour
l'avenir de notre pays
au fond c'est assez simple si comme nous
vous le pensez alors votre rôle à vous
est absolument déterminant alors nous
allons sortir du provisoire pour la
première fois et évidemment ça va amener
à une meilleure organisation entre nous
j'étais un peu le tiers de confiance
le capitaine du démarrage je suis
toujours mais évidemment efforts que
l'équipe se réorganise chacun au fond
c'est on a fait tout ça de manière
spontanée en fonction des disponibilités
des uns et des autres mais maintenant il
faut qu'on ait un système critique
moi je me suis engueulé récemment avec
les différentes chaînes de radio de
télévision parce qu'il me disait affirmé
jean louis borloo sinon on prend
quelqu'un d'autre et chaleur diem
attendez vous êtes très gentil mais
quand vous faites des émissions devaient
avoir les différentes sens politique
or nous sommes à cet or si la troisième
force politique de notre pays
et je leur disais je sais bien que vous
avez vos habitudes chemin vous
connaissez toujours les mêmes des
invités toujours les mêmes sauf que
l'udps et doit être représenté dans
toutes les grandes émissions de débat
politique et c'est pas à bout on va pas
mettre du borloo tous les matins je dire
d'abord parce que c'est très mauvais
pour moi
non mais tout simplement d'abord parce
qu'on a une diversité aussi de
sensibilité même si on est d'accord sur
l'essentiel c'est pas eu à décider et
que la force politique qu'elle repose
pas sur un homme d'abord parce que c'est
trop facile il suffit lui de le décider
et puis comme ça en est tranquille sur
la force politique non nous sommes une
équipe
mais vraiment et donc on va évoluer sur
tout cela
ça va me permettre d'alléger un peu et
de me consacrer à l'essentiel de
l'essentiel que nous déciderons ensemble
alors la première bataille que vous avez
devant vous
l'animation débat démocratique dans vos
fédérations de débats politiques la
première bataille ces démunis c'est à
hervé on a parlé excellemment tout à
l'heure moi je vous affirme qu'il doit y
avoir une signature u10 cette signature
udc quoi c'est la liberté d'entreprendre
le dynamisme la maîtrise des impôts le
travail en réseau entre républicains car
on ne dirige pas des collectivités en
étant sectaire c'est strictement
impossible
un possible le développement durable qui
est vita dans les collectivités
absolument vital ça va des des plans
climat énergie au plan de transport doux
le dynamisme économique évidemment elles
travaillent en réseau
ça c'est notre signature dans un esprit
républicain et de solidarité vous savez
l'action publique ça doit emmener un
peuple le peuple d'une commune le peuple
d'une ville dans ses contradictions vers
l'avenir et en même temps être très
attentif aux plus fragiles physiquement
je sais les plus fragiles qui ont besoin
de l'action publique plus que les autres
c'est les plus fragiles qui ont besoin
de l'action collective plus que les
autres donc voilà des projets qui seront
de développement durable de liberté
dynamisme économique de respect
républicain capable de créer de la
cohésion et du travail en réseau ça sera
de la marque
udi de la campagne municipale et
puisqu'on en est là je vous demande
d'aider tous nos candidats
ils ont besoin elles ont besoin de vous
la liste des 200 premières investiture
est arrêté on va les communiquer à
chacune et à chacun étant libre lui-même
d'en parler sur son territoire certains
préfèrent attendre
c'est dans le respect de chacun chaque
liste elle est prête si libre rudy hervé
nous l'avons ai travaillé ensemble et on
se rend compte dans le détail qui l'y a
énormément de territoires sur lesquels
7,7 pas tu dis lorsqu'il ya la rencontre
d'une femme et d'un homme fin d'une
équipe d'un territoire et de lully et
bien les sondages que nous avons sont
très spectaculaires
il y a une dizaine de sondages qui nous
donnent gagnants dans ces grandes aux
moyennes à grandes villes moyennes où
pouvait le moyenne tout court
hervé faisait l'allusion un conte a
récupéré hier ou avant-hier ou même en
primaire nous sommes devant et nous
sommes les seuls à battre l'actuel
candidat sortant deux du parti
socialiste et et de la coalition de
gauche donc cette bataille municipale
elle doit être fondée sur des valeurs
mais c'est une bataille municipale que
nous allons gagner j'en ai aucun doute
alors dans le nord le grand test dans le
grand sud-ouest dans le centre on
pourrait bien des zones
je n'exclus pas le reste bien entendu à
nouméa
à la réunion avec la gourgue convaincu
que le futur maire de nouméa sera une
femme une femme de ludique vous
connaissez tous mais on voit que
l'outre-mer sera une grande victoire
municipal de l'ue et alors
c'est la première bataille qui nous faut
livrer de manière absolue extrêmement
forte
finalement vous avez voulu cette
formation politique nous avions dit
indépendante dans son organisation
allait nous avions dit indépendante dans
ses choix politiques
elle l'est nous avions dit indépendant
dans ces financements elle est
indépendant dans ses investitures
elle est l'indépendance n'est pas un
slogan mais une tactique d' alliances de
circonstance c'est le fruit d'une vision
est celle fruit d'une organisation
mais l'indépendance n'est pas
l'isolément les démocraties occidentales
fonctionne avec des coalitions
la france ne fait pas exception à cette
règle alors oui nous avons vocation à
établir une coalition avec la droite
républicaine humaniste et républicaine
dans laquelle de manière loyale mais
dans lequel il y aura forcément des
frottements des frictions et des débats
mais nous n'avons pas vocation à ne pas
savoir où nous habitons ou à changer
évidemment de coalition
récit nous avons aujourd'hui les
fondations de la maison savez c'est très
important que vous soyez là
démocratiquement élu finalement c'est
pas si facile dans les formations
politiques de faire des votes
démocratiques apparemment donc c'est
très important parce que c'est le
fondement de la puissance de l'avenir
mais cette maison commune nous ne
l'avons pas bâti pour nous retrouver
ensemble même si il ya un côté
extrêmement fière chaleureux on se sent
mieux son plus fort on sent plus
puissant mais nous l'avons bâtie pour
servir les français
pas pour nous servir les français dans
un monde qui évolue à toute vitesse ce
qui a été évoqué pendant toute la
matinée par nos intervenants elles
refont très bien qu'on ait installé dans
les territoires assez clairement
et maintenant il faut qu'ils aient
l'accord coordination entre le drapeau
et sa visibilité installe réellement les
motifs de nos combats alors notre
drapeau
nos drapeaux c'est celui de la liberté
la liberté d'entreprendre la liberté
d'innover la liberté pour un chef
d'établissement d'organiser ces équipes
pédagogiques et les moyens pour venir en
aide aux plus fragiles ce qui n'est
toujours pas fait aujourd'hui notre
drapeau
c'est la liberté mais notre à pau c'est
aussi la réforme est là respect de la
république dans le respect de chacun
dans ce monde en plein bouleversement
savez la réforme c'est l'adaptation
c'est un concept absolument vital te le
disais avait tout à l'heure à tout
organisme vivant
la réforme c'est la vie le déni et
l'immobilisme c'est la mort
la réforme c'est aussi le fruit d'une
analyse aux profondeurs de notre espoir
est de notre organisation
confronté aux besoins d'un monde moderne
fait de vitesse ne mobilité
d'interconnexion et d'innovation et je
voudrais revenir sur eux qui a été
évoqué à de nombreuses reprises tout à
l'heure paritarisme et agences au fond
nous vivons dans un monde global qui
bouge et le débat politique de son qui
est posée la philosophie politique
c est ce que nous voulons prendre notre
part nos enfants prennent le pas leur
part dans cette croissance mondiale et
internationales dans ce monde
d'innovation du numérique de bien
d'autres dans ce monde des réseaux dans
ce monde d'ouverture ou est-ce que nous
dénions cette réalité et nous voulons
nous refermer sur nous-mêmes et nous
voulons avoir des des lignes maginot
dans les quartiers dans les coeurs et
autour de notre pays
la question fondamentale qui est posée à
notre pays et celle là alors la liberté
c'est c'est celle d'entreprendre et de
respecter l'autre
je pense que la grande question qui nous
est posée c'est ce que nous sommes le
parti qui comprend et porte cette grande
vague d'innovations qui monte partout
dans le monde
est ce que nous voulons être le parti
qui relèvent ces grands défis du 21ème
siècle qui sont autant de chance et de
nouvelles frontières au fond est ce que
nous voulons être le parti du nouveau
monde
le parti qui attire comme l'évoqué un
intervenant ce matin les forces les
classe créative
de nos sociétés où tout se mélange le
numérique la la musique l'ingéniosité la
proximité le service à la personne
la biologie et biochimie la mer et ses
technologies est un monde qui bouge
complètement et qui est un système
d'atomisation avec des noyaux durs c'est
ça la question est-ce que nous sommes à
partie du 19e et du 20e siècle où un
parti du 21e siècle
au fond moi je me souviens très bien
dans un article un titre avait fait en
1989 dans une ville qui m'est cher en
arrondissement qui m'est chère ainsi
qu'à consiste à kemer dominique ou
valérie le plus grand dam que nous
avions à l'époque je vous dire ce
n'était pas les 40 me licencie bien sûr
que c'est un drame mais le pire des
drames c'est les 44 milles départ
c'était l'exode des talents et la vraie
question qui est posée aujourd'hui à
notre pays c'est la faim ou pas de
l'exode de nos talents l'ensemble de nos
talents tous nous allons alors nous
avons des débats d'orientation mais
comme nous sommes des gens pragmatiques
nous avons nous vous avons proposé de de
valider un certain nombre de mesures
d'extrême urgence pourquoi nous l'avons
fait parce que nous avons constaté avec
les parlementaires sénat ait semblé
qu'un certain nombre d' évidence absolue
pouvait être corrigé que le nouvel le
nouveau gouvernement s'était trompé sur
un seul nombre de points époux font en
hausse
tout le monde était d'accord ça ses
erreurs et ce n'est pas pour leur casser
les pieds c'est simplement parce que la
crise française
la nôtre est aggravée par un centre de
mesures sur lesquelles on pouvait
revenir
et ce qui est terrible et ce qui est
terrible c'est que quand on les
rencontre gauche l'ump cologie ce tout
le monde est d'accord là dessus
la tva sur l'efficacité énergétique des
bâtiments
la tva sur l'amélioration de l'habitat
la tva sur le logement social 100 %
d'augmentation pour payer le
déséquilibre du marché
non seulement ils sont d'accord pour
revenir dessus mais ce qu'ils nous
disent c'est oui mais pas maintenant
janvier
résultat tout s'arrête est ce que vous
connaissez vous une mesure
d'amélioration annoncé où les gens
n'attendent pas qu'elles soient votées
avant de continuer à travailler dans ce
secteur
c'est dramatique
ils font toujours d'accord mais il ya la
posture on n'y arrive pas c'est vrai des
services à la personne nous en est je
vous en ai pas les secteurs qui créent
120 130 mille emplois qui vont détruire
3 à 400 me cette année malheureusement
est probablement on est sur des sujets
d'urgence vous les avez je vais pas vous
voulez vous les énumérer qui dans quatre
cinq cent mille emplois de plus de moi
ces 15 milliards en plus ou en moins de
déficit de l'ensemble des comptes
publics
et moi je vous le dit les déficits cette
année vont s'aggraver vont s'aggraver
beaucoup on va atteindre les 100
milliards de déficit sur 280 milliards
de recettes et c'est pour ça que nous
hurlons nous crions sur ces mesures
durant sauf à nous démontrer qu'elles
sont inopérantes ce que je crois pas un
quart de seconde
donc ce que vous avez validé c'est ce
que nous vous avons demandé les mesures
de vent et que le gouvernement nous
écoute qu'il nous écoute
un autre grand chantier qu'on leur a
proposées savez quel est le le plus
grand facteur de relocalisation de
nos activités c'est évidemment les sept
centrales d'achat c'est bien les sept
centrales d'achat qui décident tous les
jours quels sont les produits qui vont
être en vente sur le territoire national
alors je parle de cette centrale d'achat
distribution mais on pourrait ajouter
les centrales d'achat industriel bien
entendu voir le système aujourd'hui
c'est que l'analyse des prix est
strictement le prix dits économiques
c'est-à-dire pour 5 centimes deux mois à
dix mille kilomètres si le coût du
transport apparent n'est que de 4
centimes
eh bien on préférera faire un produit
faire venir un produit à dix mille
kilomètres lorsque nous demandons
centrale d'achat c'est que soit intégrer
le coût carbone de chacun des produits
qu'ils intègrent au moment du choix le
coût carbone ou écologique des produits
le vrai coût économique
le vrai coup de faire concurrence
écologique et sociale et vous verrez à
ce moment là la puissance de
relocalisation non pas franco française
mais dans tous les cas de proximité que
cela entraînera je crois que ce sont des
mesures d'urgence extrêmement importante
et si on n'arrive pas à avoir un débat
là-dessus et bien on pourra le traité
par d'autres moins et puis nous avons
les grandes réformes structurelles
celles pour lesquelles nous sommes
présents alors il y en a quatre ou cinq
qui ont été évoqués tout à l'heure par
par hervé hamon avant sur les mesures
d'urgence jeu et revenir parce que on
est vraiment dans le dans la folie pure
ou gallois a raison où il a tort ou le
gouvernement dit il faut baisser les
charges de 20 milliards où il a tort il
faut pas le faire mais pas tellement on
dit qu'il faut le faire
ce crédit d'impôt compétitivité emploi
et simplement fait pour que ça ne se
fasse pas
si on veut baisser les charges on les
baisse il ya quelque chose que je
n'arriverai jamais à comprendre c'est
pourquoi quand on dit qu'on baisse les
charges on les baisse pas et on a
inventé un truc qui passe par le
percepteur dont on sait qu'à cette
heure-ci au bout de six mois ça va
toucher moins de 2% des entreprises 450
millions d'euros et non pas les 20
milliards qui était prévu ou alors on
dit on ne fait pas on suit l'extrême
gauche c'est un cadeau fait aux
entreprises donc c'est pas la baisse
mais on fait pas semblant c'est ce
sentiment de faire semblant totalement
déroutant pour la confiance de notre
économie les choses sont simples on fait
on fut pas si chacun s'adapte on dit on
arrête de l'aggravation du prélèvement
obligatoire où on dit voilà on hormis
encore pour trois points et après on en
fit plus mais ce sentiment de méfiance
de non confiance dans l'avenir et le
principal frein au redéploiement
économie dionadji à l'aller les points
structurelles revenons-en au point au
point structurelles
le coût du travail la baisse beaucoup
l'histoire du cic a pas se faire comme
ça s'il y aura pas les chats il va bien
donc falloir la faire durer n'étaient
pas financés comme la très très très
justement fait remarquer jean arthuis
mais elle avait pas besoin d'être lancée
puisqu'il est d'ores et déjà prévu que
ça fonctionnerait pas donc elle joua pas
il ya une eau pour une fois une total
cohérence entre la recette et la dépense
mon chargeur
en fait bercy n'était pas d'accord vous
savez merci considère toujours que comme
ils disent comment tu perds ton ministe
enfin bon déclaration politique mon
affaire mécanismes pour s'assurer à peu
près que ça va pas fonctionner parce que
c'est pas en fait c'est pas très bien
maintenant les coûts du travail
il faut une rupture c'est ce que propose
le document une rupture massive ces 40 à
50 milliards là on peut discuter de deux
niveaux de l'entreprise de la penne
enfin discuter d'un ensemble de choses
mais je pense que nous ne coupons pas à
revenir à l'équivalence sur le coût du
travail par rapport à nos amis allemands
le deuxième grand sujet parce que c'est
la même chose c'est la durée annuelle de
travail
hervé la secouer le cocotier de manière
un peu un peu fort tout à l'heure mais
la réalité ce qui va bien falloir qu'on
travaille comme pour les retraites on
peut faire semblant pas regarder le
sujet la vérité c'est qu'on va
travailler plus longtemps et le document
d'orientation des voix là il faut le
faire alors on explique on ça va être le
débat qui va être lancé quelles
compensations pour les salariés il faut
qu'il la productivité évidemment comme
le dit le document
il faudra qu'il ya une une compo station
puissante sur alors où les salaires la
baisse des charges des salariés bref il
faudra qu'on trouve et c'est tout le
débat mais on a même travaillé des
heures et des heures sur le rachat du
droit travail et des experts disent en
bas finalement est-ce qu'on pourrait pas
racheter collectivement pour dix ou
quinze mille euros par part salarié se
voit finalement fin mai sortir de ce
sujet là me paraît tout à fait
inévitable on discutera des avantages de
compétitivité et des compensations pour
les salariés mais restent les deux
problèmes qui ont été évoqués tout à
l'heure qui me paraissent moi tout à
fait cruciaux c'est celui de
l'émiettement je m'explique tout notre
modèle est fondé sur
trim one auquel nous sommes très
attachés qui est le paritarisme du
conseil national de la résistance et
l'organisation administrative vers la
décentralisation et 2 c'est que nous
sommes une famille de la
décentralisation
mais aujourd'hui tout ça a évolué les
ordres de grandeur on les connaît
recettes de l'état 280 milliards
quand on parle de la réforme de l'état
280 milliards les recettes des
collectivités de sang du paritarisme
selon les le périmètre que l'on prend de
650 à 950
comprenez moi bien le débat n'est pas de
remettre en cause ces principes là mais
de savoir si dans ces mille feuille
administratif la décentralisation sap a
été comment en organise ce qui doit
relever de l'état ce qui doit relever
des régions et de la proximité c'était
des concessions en réalité au fur et à
mesure avec des strass complète
gouvernement précédent avait voulu que
chaque collectivité soit spécialisé en
est revenue dessus c'est la clause
générale de compétence tout le monde
peut participer au financement d'un
boulodrome
je suis arrivé à saint saulve oui à
boulodrome avec un financement du
département de la région de la ville de
l'agglomération des fonds européens et
de l'état au titre du fonds national de
la jeunesse et des sports
formidable ce n'est pas tout nam des
enfants le millefeuille n'est pas tous
deux la même manière le paritarisme de
dialogue social le débat s'est pas
centralisation décentralisant c'est
notre organisation est le débat s'est
pas dialogue social évidemment qu'il
faut un dialogue social beaucoup plus
puissants d'ailleurs qui n'est
aujourd'hui avec des syndicats peu
puissant et probablement une incitation
par le chèque syndical quelque chose qui
fasse que ce soit encore plus puissant
mais ce que faut-il pour autant qu'il y
ait des centaines voire des milliers
d'opérateurs du paritarisme et il est
vraiment indispensable qui autant d'opca
d'organismes collecteurs que ce soit du
logement de la formation professionnelle
parce que à quoi arrive-t-on à la fin
prenez l'exemple de la formation
professionnelle tout simplement la
formation professionnelle
avait cinquante mille entreprises agrées
très bien vous avez des centaines de
collecteurs qui eux-mêmes oriente vous
avez un nombre d'opérateurs chambre de
commerce forme de montier branche région
et arts et à la fin de la journée pour
les 31 milliards il ya que 10% qui
arrive en véritable qualification des
travailleurs ceux qui sont en besoin de
qualification ou demandeurs d'emploi ou
à la jeunesse donc sans remettre en
cause la légitimité de chacun il nous
faut une politique globale définie une
cabine de pilotage unique une nouvelle
gouvernance des dépenses publiques vous
pouvez pas voir le millefeuille
administratif
et puis l'émiettement du paritarisme
opérationnel et donc ce cette
réorientation de la gouvernance par
grands sujets logement santé formation
qualification professionnelle et
apprentissage va falloir qu'on le
remette à plat dans une totale
transparence en en discutant évidemment
avec tous les acteurs et les partenaires
sociaux
on n'est pas obligé faire des fusions de
structures que ça me remet tout
abandonner dans la même cabine de
pilotage tout le monde apporte ses
compétences son savoir-faire ses
financements comme ça a été fait pour la
rénovation urbaine des banlieues on a
créé un tout petit outil de rien du tout
qui gère 43 milliards et qui à éviter
l'émiettement et probablement des drames
extrêmement important dans nos quartiers
donc oui nous vous demandons mandat pour
réfléchir un paritarisme moderne et pour
réfléchir andré organisation
territoriale avec qui fait quoi dans cet
émiettement on vit avec l'idée d'un état
centralisé
alors qu'en réalité nous sommes dans une
société où il est temps et centralisée
et lourd bureaucratique méfiant mais on
vit dans une société qui est totalement
émietté parmi ces opérateurs
je sais que ce sont des concepts qui
sont pas des concepts de grandes
réunions publiques mais c'est quand même
le mandat que nous vous avons demandé il
serait qu'elle nous
nous allons travailler après les
municipales
j'allais dire en même temps que les
notre drapeau puisque c'est l'ouverture
sur le monde c'est évidemment
l'ouverture sur l'europe et donc
l'europe et ce sera donc juin 2000 2014
au fond vont s'affronter ce qui en
france propose le repli identitaire à
ceux qui proposent d'armes et la nation
dans ce grand monde d'innovation en
faisant attention aux plus fragiles et
dans un respect total de la république
au fond le débat il est là et au fond
ils vont essayer de 2 voilà deux de
reporter sur sur l'autre
l'autre c'est parce qu'il n'a pas la
même couleur ou pas la même formation
pas le même territoire ou en
l'occurrence les européens les allemands
bref nos échecs nos difficultés le
logement la compétitivité le coût du
travail
c'est ça ce qui va ce qu'ils vont
essayer de faire alors que nous nous
savons que l'europe a des défauts
qu'elle n'est pas exemptes de critiques
au bout de ces trente premières années
évidemment et dieu sait que j'en qui
fait la tournée des capitales
on est en train de voir se dessiner une
absolue nécessaire évolution de notre
europe
évidemment nous avons besoin d'une
europe d'un airbus du numérique et du
contrôle des données
vous voyez ce qui se passe actuellement
aux etats unis c'est absolument vital
d'airbus du ferroviaire
un airbus du transport maritime bref
nous avons besoin de cette europe là et
nous savons que la lutte contre les
paradis fiscaux
mise en place même si elle va être tous
il de la taxe sur les transactions
financières de la taxe carbone aux
frontières tout ça ne peut se faire qu'à
l'échec d'un bloc continent mais je vois
bien que ce combat sera rude mais c'est
notre drapeau et nous serons évidemment
à la pointe de ce combat parce que c'est
c'est pas parce qu'on est un parti
européen parce que c'est l'état d'esprit
d'ouverture à l'égard à l'égard du monde
et puis parce que l'europe c'est ça
reste un projet de paix ça reste un
projet de droits de l'homme
ça reste un projet de défense des femmes
ça reste un projet profondément
démocratique
alors oui l'europe doit être recentrée
sur l'essentiel mais nous serons à la
pointe de ce combat là et aura des
modifications à faire
on voit bien que la directive services
connaît quelques dérapages qui a pas
cette contrôle notamment dans le secteur
du bâtiment mais on aura l'occasion de
de parler tout cela en fait la question
de savoir qui nous sommes
je pense vraiment nous sommes les
garants d'ouverture d'esprit
les garande de l'intégration
républicaine de la lutte contre le
déterminisme social
nous sommes pour la liberté
d'entreprendre
mais sommes nous croyons en l'avenir et
à ces opportunités
nous croyons que tout demandeur d'emploi
est une pépite disponible de la nation
ce qui n'empêche pas des règles
extrêmement rigoureux de fonctionnement
du système social oui c'est pas un
hasard si nous sommes les grands
défenseurs de nos territoires et
départements d'outre-mer ou grande
majorité des députés d'outre-mer sont
dans
groupe c'est pas hasard est ce que ce
sont nos frères qui gère dans la
complexité républicaine des cultures
différentes qui peuvent être l'avant
garde pour nous d'un projet de
développement durable dans death
écosystème où c'est possible et voire
même indispensable
bref nous sommes ce parti de la
modernité de la liberté d'ouverture
nous devons être l'alternative et
renouer avec les déçus les inquiet et
les révoltés
c'est une réponse responsabilité
historique vous avez c'est le terrain le
terrain les gens vous bien ce qui se
passe en europe dans cette crise qu'est
ce qui va se passer
la coalition quelle va être la future
coalition
le terrain va va pousser à à ce que nos
amis de l'ump soient attirés vers
d'autres cieux je mets pas en cause du
tout les dirigeants ce passage que je
dis mais la seule vraie coalition ça
sera la coalition udi ump c'est pour ça
que vous avez une responsabilité
totalement historique beaucoup plus
importante que que vous que vous pensez
c'est pas juste l'occupation d'un espace
on est à un moment qui peut être un
moment troublée de l'histoire de notre
pays ou un moment au contraire plein
d'initiatives alors puisque nous avons
le temps de nous consacrer à l'essentiel
faisons le parce que notre pays en a
besoin parce que vous êtes là y compris
dans dans la salle à côté que vous êtes
venus de tous les départements de
métropole et d'outre-mer parce que vous
le voulez parce que nous sommes
véritable espoir parce que nous sommes
la france de ses 36000 communes parce
que nous sommes la république et sa
diversité
parce que la liberté c'est l'énergie et
la solidarité c'est la réussite
collective
c'est la croyance en l'avenir c'est
notre pays
c'est pour ça que vous vous engagez
l'europe est notre destin
le monde et notre vision vives lui dis
vive la république et vive la france
jean lui